you've heard what the political experts
predict for tonight's State of the Union
address but what about the experts in
America's heartland
the voters tonight senior correspondent
Mike Tobin talks to the people in one
politically savvy Michigan County about
what they expect to hear nestled on the
banks of Lake Michigan the people in
South Haven have picked every president
except Carter in the last 15 elections
Michigan's van buren county is a mix of
farms agribusiness manufacturing and
small business as a result residents on
the right and the left can agree this
place is neither right nor left it's
kind of an interesting melting pot I
guess over coffee and hashbrown Trump
supporters expect a pep rally from the
president tonight celebrating a bounce
in the economy and the return of jobs I
hope to hear him get up there and talk
about the accomplishments that have been
made because I don't think enough
attention has been given to them and
we're already starting to see the
benefits from tax reform I think there's
a lot of dovetailing that can happen
with the Michigan turnaround
others who didn't vote for Trump say
there's nothing he can say to win them
over he's gonna have to build action and
trust over time I mean and so far this
first year he's done none of that I
don't think we're gonna hear anything
new tonight they anticipate the
president revisiting promises to invest
in infrastructure and highways and
foreign policy people are happy with the
president's action in Israel some want a
message of peace through strength one
veteran just wants the president to be
quiet
I sure do want to hear about from North
Korea because all he does is keep around
on the cage and specially somebody's
gonna pull trigger in a farming area
that ultimately sees a lot of migrant
labor the people here want resolution on
immigration I want to hear him say that
he's gonna secure the border before
anybody gets any citizenship through it
all Van Buren County voters want to hear
a unifying voice amid the bitter
partisan divide in Congress and across
the heartland I'm looking for a positive
tone I think the president is
and to bridge some gaps here and get
some bipartisan support and he's trying
pretty hard to be a unifier but one side
doesn't want to unify it is polarized
but I'm not sure he's helped to stop
that people here say the voices that get
hurt are the elite in DC or New York
entertainers in LA Heart lenders who get
up in the morning and put food on the
table feel forgotten and a majority here
got a message from the Trump campaign
that he gets them and they're hoping
hear it again tonight
Bret Mike Tobin in South Haven Michigan
Mike thanks